we have some good news out of the
Illinois State House of Representatives
which has just passed a bill that if
eventually signed into law would
automatically register state residents
to vote when they walk into one of
several different types of government
offices
this would hugely streamline the voter
registration process you would no longer
need to mail in any forms or wait or
anything
it passed the House 115 to zero it had
already passed the Senate 49 sorry 40 48
to zero and now it goes back to the
Senate for tweaking you might know that
a similar bill actually made it through
the Illinois legislature last year but
it was vetoed by their Republican
governor Bruce rauner who cited quote
voter fraud as a reason to be against
this which is of course bogus first
because in-person voter fraud just isn't
a problem and second because registering
people to vote automatically is a
completely separate process from
whatever ID requirement there may be to
actually do the voting on voting day a
proponents are pointing out this would
actually make it even harder for people
to register illegally because your name
already has to be on a pre constructed
list of eligible voters at whatever
state agency you show up at so this is
actually one of those cases where it's
all about suppressing turnout this is a
partisan issue although it shouldn't be
because it involves more people voting
which is always bad for Republicans
Republicans don't want more people to
vote it's not exactly democratic is it
Pat to try to reduce the number of
people participating in the democratic
process yeah and of course we're talking
about small d-- democratic-- but it's
also not tap will be democratic either
it's not either right because you are
more likely to be obstructing the votes
of Democrats than Republicans when you
make it more difficult for people to
register to vote and to actually vote on
voting day people might forget that
Republicans not only push voter
suppression at the polling places but
also in the voter registration process a
runner is still the governor he says he
will sign it this time we will see
regardless the General Assembly in
Illinois right now has a majority so
large that they actually would likely be
able to override a gubernatorial veto
even if the governor did veto it
State should have this it's common sense
this is removing a step in the
registration process we're not talking
about IDs at voting precinct precincts
and really truly automatic voting per se
would be even better like in Canada you
don't have to be registered you just
show up at the polls because you're
already on a list by default even the
concept of registering to vote is one
that could be done away with if there
was a commitment to increasing voter
turnout yeah it's easy to forget that
voting is a right it's not like it's a
privilege like driving and of course
there's this administrative step you
have to take where you have to register
right but if we just do things like this
or have automatic voter straight voter
registration when you turn 18 or right
same-day voter registration when you go
to the polls that's a step in the right
direction and again it's all sort of
suppressed with this vague explanation
of voter fraud and what Republicans mean
by that is in-person voter fraud right
someone showing up and claiming to be
twenty different people to vote twenty
times or people showing up with their
name in ten different districts this
effectively doesn't happen I think you
you know the numbers better than I do in
the 2016 election I think that there
were for example or examples three of
which were definitive Trump voters right
not necessarily Trump voters but they
were registered Republicans we know one
person voted early they voted for Trump
so again trying to solve a problem that
does not exist discuss this with us on
our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash reddit today's program
is made possible in part by taga dabbe
the hosting specialist taga dab offers a
broad range of affordable and flexible
hosting packages including dedicated
servers virtual private servers cloud
server options as well as custom server
solutions and uk-based colocation
services over 70% of taga DAB's business
comes from repeat orders from existing
customers and recommendations from
existing customers and this is really a
testament to the support that taga dabbe
provides their customers you can get by
virtue of being a listener or viewer of
the david pakman show a 10 British Pound
free credit for your new account by
signing up at signup
jagad AB comm /t dps and of course by
supporting our sponsors you're also
supporting the David Pakman show